foreign
wow
what an incredible warm welcome from you
all and can I tell you that it is the
honor of my life
to be here as the new leader of the SMP
and you may have picked up
been a few challenges in the first 12
weeks
and through some of those
difficult days it is you our incredible
members that have Lifted Me Up you have
given me heart
you have given me energy so from the
bottom of my heart thank you for all the
support that you have given me our party
and our cause
friends it is great to be here with you
of course in the yes city of Dundee
famously as you will know it's a city of
the three G's jam and Joe Fitzpatrick of
course as well
uh this is a city which in many ways
represents the very best of Scotland
rightly proud of its industrial heritage
but also constantly Reinventing itself
to stay at The Cutting Edge
and today it's home of some of the key
industries that will power Scotland's
future
today as We Gather to discuss that
future I cannot tell you how much of an
honor it is to be addressing you as the
new SNP leader
the SNP is a party that is often made
history
and I stand here today as the first ever
Muslim and first ever ethnic minority
first minister
it
it is proof
if ever we needed it that we are truly
the National Party of Scotland and that
is something that each and every single
one of us should be proud of
we've come a long way on Scotland's
journey to Independence
we certainly haven't traveled as fast as
we'd like we've had some difficult times
and of course as I've already mentioned
the last few months haven't been easy
but down the years the road towards
independence has been paved by the
determination by the spirit of thousands
who came before us and nobody but nobody
typifies that determination and that
Spirit more than Winnie Ewing
the political earthquake that when he
caused with her violate with her Victory
her Sensational victory in Hamilton in
1967 it's still resonates to this very
day
and over the decades whether in
Westminster or Brussels or just as we
saw in that clip reconvening the
Scottish Parliament when he helped shape
the Modern Nation that we are today
she had an unshakable belief in the
potential of the Scottish people and she
never stopped trying to inspire
confidence and ambition in those around
her and there is no exaggeration none
whatsoever
to say that we would not be here
today were it not for winning
with her passing this week
we mourn someone who was both a patriot
and a pioneer to Madame ecos from the
bottom of our hearts we say thank you
for everything
thank you
friends the success of the SNP in
winning elections over the years
has allowed us to make a real difference
for the people of Scotland and what a
difference we have made an estimated 90
000 children in Scotland being lifted
out of poverty by our actions record
levels of foreign investment in our
economy unemployment at near record low
levels that's the difference that the
SNP makes the best paid nurses in the
whole of the UK a global leader a global
leader in climate Justice an education
system
based on the ability to learn not on the
ability to pay that's the difference
that the SNP makes
friends the SNP is building a fair arm
or prosperous
and a more confident Scotland and that's
the difference that the SNP makes
today we are talking about how we build
on those successes
we know that the most transformational
step Scotland can take towards building
a better future is to become an
independent nation and we are within
touching distance of achieving our goal
Independence is Within Reach and today
I'm going to set out how I believe we
can break the Log Jam with Westminster
by mobilizing the power of the people at
the next general election because
friends make no mistake about it the SNP
will absolutely fight the next general
election with Independence front and
center of our campaign
be another
and that's because choosing between
Tories or Tory light well that's no real
choice at all the real alternative the
real alternative to Westminster control
is taking our future into our own hands
as an independent nation we all know
that Scotland faces challenges we know
we live in an uncertain world
but as Scotland's national party it is
our duty
in these tough times to give people some
hope
and imagine a better future with the
endless opportunities that Independence
gives us
we must inspire people and make it
abundantly clear Westminster is not as
good as it gets
we can do better than the failed
Westminster economic model that is
causing such misery
friends if only one message leaves this
conference Hall today let it be this
with our vast natural resources our
economic strength with our world-class
universities and of course with the
talent of all of our people and
independent Scotland can and will be one
of the most successful nations in the
entire world
no one
no one absolutely no one will take
better decisions for Scotland
than you the people who live here
after all it's the people who live here
who have the biggest stake in Scotland's
future no one can better Steward our
resources no one can better nurture our
talent the evidence of why Independence
works is quite literally all around us
all we have to do is look to our
European neighbors and we get a glimpse
of what Scotland future can be
whether we're talking about Norway
whether we're talking about Ireland
whether we're talking about
that's okay
that's okay folks
folks let's not boom
I'll tell you what folks
I'll tell you what folks let's not boo
I'm going to take a minute to talk about
that person everybody because we are we
are
[Applause]
thank you
minutes pause if we can just have a
couple of minutes pause everyone and we
will be back to the stage shortly
foreign
[Music]
you see
that everyone is here
[Music]
something else
[Applause]
friends
we are we enjoy this success we do and
let us never ever forget this we enjoy
the success we do because we care for
each and every single person in Scotland
and we might
we might not always get it right heck I
know I've not always got it right in
government myself
but we'll never stop listening to people
we'll not shout them down we'll not boo
them we will always listen to them
[Applause]
right
I was saying folks that the evidence
for why Independence works is quite
literally all around us
all we have to do is look to our
European neighbors and we get a glimpse
of what Scotland's future can be
whether we're talking about Norway
Ireland Denmark Sweden
Austria Finland they're comparable to
Scotland and they're outperforming the
UK in many ways they're wealthier they
have fewer people living in poverty they
have higher levels of investment they're
more productive that means they have
more money to fund Public Services like
their schools and like their hospitals
and when times are tough like when the
cost of living started to bite
they had broader shoulders to weather
the storm and Friends
you know what else
every single one of these countries is
an independent nation
[Applause]
each country had their own path to
success
but in every case success is exactly
what Independence has led to
the question we
in Scotland must ask ourselves it's not
why are our neighbors more successful
than us
the question we must ask
is why not Scotland
with our abundant energy resources some
of the best universities in the world
both are hugely successful Financial
Services with our cutting-edge life
sciences with our renowned
world-renowned food and drink sector
with a gallus intelligent good humored
hard working population
why not Scotland
[Applause]
friends Independence works
and there is absolutely no doubt that
Independents can and will work for
Scotland never let anyone tell you
otherwise
emulating the success of our neighbors
will not happen automatically
but the whole point of Independence is
to make transformational change by
taking power into our own hands
and the SNP
is setting up a Clear Vision for how we
would change things for the better
and what you get with Independence is
this
you get the powers to build an economy
that puts the health and the happiness
of its citizens at his heart
not an Economy based on failed
trickle-down economics taking us in a
downward spiral
the independence you get the powers to
tackle the cost of living crisis not
being forced to suffer the biggest fall
in living standards since records began
you get the powers to build a welfare
system that protects you
not one that punishes you
you get to be inside the European Union
the world's biggest single Market not
dragged out of Europe against your will
you get an energy policy that works for
Scotland's people and works for the
planet non-energy Market designed to
work for Westminster and corporate
shareholders and friends what do you get
with Independence
you get a written Constitution
that guarantees we are a country
thank you
they have not even gone to the good bed
we get our Constitution a written
Constitution that guarantees that we are
a country which enshrines and protects
the rights of every single citizen not a
country where populist politicians strip
people of their fundamental rights
particularly from our most marginalized
communities
you get a constitutional right that
protects the NHS at the point of use
not what we see at the moment creeping
privatization from the UK government
from the Tories and with labor with
Independence and a written Constitution
we get a country
which opens its heart
and offers sanctuary
to those who flee conflict not one that
bundles them on a plane to Rwanda
and Frames without written Constitution
we get a country that bans nuclear
weapons from our soil for goods
not a country that wastes tens of
billions of pounds on the obscenity of
weapons of mass destruction
friends
Independence is about having and using
the powers to build a better country a
better Scotland is possible and over the
coming months we will continue laying
out our perspectives for building a new
Scotland
and I'll tell you what else we were
doing we'll be defending our national
Parliament from being constantly
undermined overruled sabotaged by an
increasingly erratic Westminster
government
just think about the events of the last
few weeks we are now
at the point
where our Scottish Parliament
can no longer even do something as
simple
as include glass in a recycling scheme
without Westminster muscling in at the
11th hour and sabotaging it
and while we promote Scotland as a place
to invest and do business in Capital
Cities right around the world
Westminster tries to stop us because
they claim that we're stepping above our
station
last week I got a list of our supposed
transgressions from the UK government
I have to tell your friends now I have
to be serious that's a really see this
point I have to be afraid I have to tell
you my friends I was shocked
when I found out what SNP ministers had
been up to
Ivan McKee was in Poland on a trade
mission
he was apparently overheard saying that
brexit was a mistake perish the thought
my friends
Angus Roberson
Angus Robertson was was promoting
Scottish culture at a Saint Andrews day
reception and he dared to say
that leaving the EU had negatively
impacted on student exchange programs to
Scotland an absolute shocker ladies and
gentlemen
you see for the Tories
bringing jobs and investment to Scotland
is apparently a transgression
for the SNP bringing jobs and investment
into Scotland is our national mission
I think there's maybe something else
going on here I think the Tories they
see that the SNP has made friends for
Scotland right across the world they see
our success and attract and train
investment and they're just that wee bit
jealous and they can't even hide it
but the future of our national
Parliament is under threat due to
Westminster control
and it is proof that is only through the
powers of Independence that we will be
able to take on the biggest challenges
of our age and build a better future
friends this story government that is
morally and politically bankrupt
but I just don't want rid of them for a
few years I once gotten to be
independent so we can get rid of
unelected Tory governments for good
thank you
especially especially if the alternative
is merely a pale imitation
we don't need a labor leader who says he
doesn't care if he sounds conservative
we don't need a labor leader who somehow
seems to break promises faster than he
makes them
you know it's funny with each broken
promise that kierstamer says that it's
just not possible it's just not possible
he says in the current climate to do
what he promised he says
possible
to have free higher education
and a publicly owned Rail and water
can't be done well I've got a wee
message for cure starmer not only is it
possible the SNP is doing it right here
in Scotland
and I'll tell you why it's possible this
because the SNP stand by what we believe
in and that is the difference the SNP
makes
many years ago President Kennedy very
famously said that the question in
politics is not what your country can do
for you but what you can do for your
country
the thing about cure stammer is that
when he comes north of the Border he
doesn't ask what he can do for Scotland
he's only interested in what Scotland
can do for a care starmer
friends
history teaches us that when democracy
movements like ours
reach a certain size in the end they
always Triumph
and that's why we're gathered here today
about how we can ensure Independence
becomes the settled well of the Scottish
people
and I have no doubt at this convention
we will have a lively and passionate
discussion I think it may have already
started
and after all
this is the cause this is the cause
that we all care deeply about
but I'm very clear
there's no route to Independence other
than through a lawful Democratic process
why
because that is the way we actually
become independent that's the way that
not only do we recognize Scotland
wants to become independent but it's the
way Europe and the world recognizes it
too
so that means we have two essential
tasks
before us
firstly we must we must
continue building support for
Independence
we've done so much and we need to keep
going
you know there was a time not all that
long ago when we were ecstatic we were
over the moon
when support for Independence reach 30
percent
now support for our cause is at least 50
50.
but secondly
we must give the people of Scotland
the opportunity to express that support
in a democratic vote
to build support
campaigning for Independence must and
will be at the heart of everything we do
as a party
that's why SMP activists that's why you
will be engaged in a summer campaign on
the opportunities of Independence
taking our message to Holmes the length
and breadth of Scotland I'm out every
week speaking to people I've been hugely
inspired to meet SNP activists across
the country
our task our Collective task is to get
Scotland talking talking about
independence
talking about the possibilities the
opportunities
to show people that there is a better
alternative
over the summer SNP members will also
continue the discussion that we are
beginning today
there'll be a series of regional
assemblies and as the summer ends we
will come together again
but this time not in a conference Hall
this time we will join the thousands of
independent activists in our nation's
capital
on the 2nd of September our friends I
believe in Scotland
will fill the streets of Edinburgh with
a March and rally for an independent
Scotland in the EU and I'm delighted to
confirm that the SNP will get fully
behind this Grassroots initiative
I will certainly be there and today I'm
calling on every single independent
supporter to come together to show our
opponents that the cause of Independence
is truly the people's movement because
the people of Scotland have always
marched and rallied for democracy and on
the 2nd of September we must do so again
so friends let's make this rally the
biggest our cause has ever seen
the SNP believes that democracy is
something to be cherished not something
to be feared
Westminster are clearly Running Scared
but there's one vote that they cannot
hide from whenever it comes and that is
the next Westminster election
that election offers us the opportunity
to break the logger
of course we will set out how we will
stand up for Scotland's interest and how
we'll mitigate the damage of Westminster
control as we always do
but friends I didn't get into politics
to Simply mitigate Westminster damage I
believe that the SNP should do much more
than that
I believe that in this election the SNP
should offer the people of Scotland a
Manifesto for an independent Scotland
a Manifesto
a Manifesto bursting with ideas about
how Scotland can harness our potential
through the powers of Independence
and Friends
in that Manifesto
page one line one
I am proposing that we put a simple but
powerful statement to the people
vote SNP for Scotland to become an
independent country
even my four-year-old got off our seat
for that one
[Applause]
friends we know how hard it is to win
elections
the poles are tight there's everything
to play for the Westminster
establishment will rail against us
but we know that Independence is best
for Scott's future so we must give the
people of Scotland the ability to choose
that future
let me be clear
fdsnp does win this election then the
people will have spoken we will seek
negotiations with the UK government on
how we give Democratic effect to
Scotland becoming an independent nation
remember
we are not the block on a referendum a
referendum has been our plan A
Westminster are the ones who are
blocking it so whether that Democratic
effect is a referendum or simply the
general election that is for them to
answer
they told Scotland
this is a voluntary Union
prove it
[Applause]
the friends
we're not going to wait for Westminster
if we win the general election
we will take that mandate from the
people and ensure that we as a
government are ready to negotiate our
independence we will take the following
actions
firstly we will set out a detailed
document
documenting the terms we would seek in
discussion with the UK government for
Scotland becoming an independent country
it will be called withdrawal from
Westminster a new partnership agreement
this new partnership agreement between
Scotland and our friends in the rest of
the UK would include draft legal text on
the transfer of powers from Westminster
to the Scottish Parliament necessary to
prepare for Independence
if we set out the Scottish government's
possession on issues such as the
division of assets that would detail
future arrangements for continuing
indeed bettering the cooperation with
the rest of the UK and place of the
assertive Westminster knows best know
your place Doctrine we can have a new a
better relationship one based on equal
partnership and based on mutual respect
secondly we will conduct our Nationwide
open and inclusive consultation on a
draft interim Constitution the founding
document of our newly independent state
and the process will include some
fundamental principles and aims to
protect citizens rights that are being
eroded by Westminster like the right of
workers to strike
to give constitutional protection for
our NHS through the point of use to
confer a duty on the government of an
independent Scotland to pursue nuclear
disarmament
and friends the first line of that
interim Constitution will say the
following
Scotland is an independent country in
which the people are sovereign
friends with Independence we will
transfer sovereignty from Westminster to
the people of Scotland
Scott and thirdly
if we win the general election we will
prepare the ground for Scotland becoming
an independent member state of the
European Union we've
we will do that by establishing an Envoy
position a representative of the
Scottish government in Brussels this
position will be focused on explaining
the Scottish government's policy on
Independence to our fellow Europeans
we will reinforce to our European
Partners our commitment to a legal
constitutional Democratic process
that we will also seek to enhance
understanding that Scotland is an
ancient Nation committed to the founding
values of the European Union a country
of course with much to gain from EU
membership
but also much to offer as we navigate
the challenges of the 21st Century
so friends with these three actions
we're not going to wait for Westminster
to respond we are going to take our
destiny into our own hands we will begin
laying the foundations of a newly
independent nation it's a vote to
deliver the powers of a country which
can build a better economy stronger
Public Services a fairer Greener society
and a Scotland free from the abomination
of weapons of mass destruction
[Applause]
friends there's a lot to talk about
today and we must consider what else we
can do what we can continue to do to
build support for Independence
what we are discussing today what we
discuss over the summer in our regional
assemblies and in our branches and
ultimately what we agree
at our National Conference in October
will be the springboard that delivers
Independence for Scotland
friends Vinnie Ewing's passing has
for all of us brought to the fore many
memories and indeed emotions over the
last couple of days
as well as the sense of loss I've been
thinking
of many people over the years who fought
their whole lives for an independent
Scotland that sadly haven't lived to see
the day
people like money
people like George Leslie people like my
mentor and friend the late and great
Basia Amit
but friends let me tell you this
when we are so close to achieving our
goal
we must take strength from them and
their legacy to push on until we win
for our families for our friends for our
communities for our country that's who
we are doing this for
and for our children our future
Generations those yet to be born
who will live in an independent Scotland
and decide how they want it to be right
in the final days of the 2014 referendum
campaign when he gave what I think was
her last filmed interview
she spoke about pride of being able to
cast her vote for an independent
Scotland and she said this
I've Waited All My Life
for a meaningful vote
I'm old enough
to appreciate having grandchildren
so I'm in a position to realize
that it's vital for them to grow up in a
fair Society
where their aspirations are listened to
and when they are afforded the chances
they need
Madame cost thank you for absolutely
nailing it
because I think about independence
and when I think about independence I
see my two girls
Maya and Amal who are in the front row
I won't lie it's hard for this Dad to
think of his girls one day leaving our
home and making a life for themselves
I'll be a greeting mess trust me when it
happens
but as parents that's all we want
we want our children
to be happy
I want our children to be healthy we
want them to make decisions
over their own lives
to make decisions
a strong independent people
that's what I want for my country too
we don't just have to imagine a better
country we can build it we can build
that better country by becoming
independent
friends I want you to think
just think for a moment
about that moment
that Scotland's Independence is declared
I want you to think
of all the Pavements you've pounded
the doors you've chant
the leaflets you've delivered
capture
how you will feel
at that very moment
when you hear the results
filtering through the news channels
that it has been confirmed
that the people of Scotland
have voted to become independent
now let that feeling motivate you
let it be the driving force
that propels us to campaign harder than
we ever have before
the SNP has a positive vision for an
independent scholar and when we leave
here today we will do so United in
making that Vision a reality
as we return to our homes to the cities
to the towns to the villages to the
highlands to the lowlands to the islands
to every Community to every street and
to every home the SNP will take that
case for a better Nation to the people
we will show them the nation we can be
and friends together we will lead
Scotland to Independence thank you very
much
thank you